okay so suppose we have the model how do
we estimate the weights the the
coefficients beta that's the question
well this was cox's i think really
ingenious idea this idea of partial
likelihood
and the magic of it is they don't have
to specify that baseline hazard which
we've been saying so nicely is
unspecified without one does not have to
specify it and still go to a good
estimate of the
coefficients beta
and we're going to use what is done is
the same kind of sequential and time
logic that was used to derive this the
capital meyer curve and the log rank
test
so
if we're at a given time y i then the
total hazard for all the people at risk
at that time
is just the sum of their hazards right
here it is
so that this is some of
all people that were still at risk at a
given they hadn't died or been censored
by time y i
okay
then suppose we look at the the relative
risk of the person who died at that time
versus all the people who are at risk
right so it kind of imagine that at a
given time we have a a bag of colored
balls
and with a certain probability we
grabbed one of them that's the ball that
had the event but we could have grabbed
one of the other ones so
the the that's what's happening here
that the people that are at risk that
could have died
here's their total risk and here's the
person that actually we observed to die
at that time here's his risk his or her
risk oh i see so you're saying
what's the chance that the person who
actually died was what's the probability
that they died
given their amount of risk right and in
the denominator you got all the risks
that were sort of adding up to the pool
exactly what's the chance it's actual
death and the very nice thing is that
being a relative risk these h0 the
baseline hazards cancel and we get a
function that's free of h0
so whatever h0 is
we don't care
we get this relative risk so this is the
probability of under the model of seeing
the person die who doubt observing the
person who died
to actually die among all those that
could have died yeah
okay
and notice the cancellation so now we
simply
just like we multiplied the kaplan
remember the capital minor we took
products of conditional probabilities
now we take
the products of these probabilities
right
which we we we just derived one for one
reset now it's for all of them
remember any
any likelihood is the
the product if you have a sample of
independent samples the the product of
the probabilities of each of the
observed samples
so yeah it's the same thing except there
these uh
this is the partial likelihood exactly
so this is in a sense the probability of
seeing of observing what we observed
under the model which is what likely it
is
and then we're going to we're going to
find the values of the parameters the
betas that make
make this the highest so
make the observed data the most likely
under the model that's what maximum
likelihood is all about
so here's an example
again the same example before we have
three failures the gold circles and
these censored observations
and
these are the relative risk functions
for each of the three failures just like
we saw before i only computed at the
death times exactly just like in capital
mirror we only compute the problem
conditional probabilities at the death
times but the censored observations they
appear in the denominators as well as
future death times and you can see them
here right
right
so
for the first failure we compute that
relative risk function for
beta
second we compute the
relativist function there third and we
take the product and this is the partial
likelihood it's just a function of beta
which is a p vector of our weights for
our features and now we maximize this
function over beta
as in the case of a lot of the mods
we've seen like logistic regression we
there's no closed form solution so we
have to apply an iterative algorithm but
have to have no problem it's done very
very easily now in software
and not only do we get what's called the
maximum likelihood estimate the partial
likelihood estimate we could the other
other goodies that we've seen in least
squares logistic regression
for example we get p-values that
correspond to political null hypothesis
like beta j equals zero
right that's often what we want to know
is a feature important is it
contributing to the risk
of a patient
as well as standard errors and
confidence intervals so all the goodies
we see from analysis of variance and
regression
we get them here in partial likelihood
as well and pressure likely
okay well we've seen the regression
method we have equation method in hand
we've seen the log rank test
remember in regression
we test for
coefficient being zero
in the case where the the regressor is
just a single zero one what we get is
something equivalent to the t-test
if we remember this from our so if it's
a linear model and you've only got a
single predictor right and let's say
it's a male female predictor zero one
right and you test its coefficient yep
and what rob's saying is that's that's
equivalent to just doing a two-sample
t-test right if it wasn't equivalent
we'd be pretty upset when we because
we'd have two very sensible ways of
of testing the same thing if they didn't
agree we'd be i think we wouldn't be
happy but
in regression they do agree and it turns
out the same thing happens here
we are now we have the log rank test and
cox's proportional has this model and
the case when there is a single
predictor taking on two values
well we could either get fit a cox
proportional hazards model or perform a
log rank test
well it turns out there's a bit of
detail in the book
to extract a test from the cox
proportional houses model there's
actually two or three different ways to
do it but one popular way is known as a
score
test and happily it turns out that in
case of a single binary covariate
the score test for testing bit equals
zero in cox's proportionalized model is
exactly equal to the log rank test
so just like the t-test and regression
agree in linear models
and gaussian emitter models the score
test for cox's proportional hazardous
model
is exactly the same as the log rank test
so it's an it's a nice tidy connection
okay some things we haven't discussed
the proportional houses model you might
have noticed that there's no intercept
in the model and why is that well if you
look back at the model if we put an
intercept here at beta0 here we'd get an
e to the beta0
which we could just absorb into h0 of t
right because that was unspecified
anyway so i can put whatever
whatever i want into here that's from
here i can transfer it into here if it's
not a function of x
and i wouldn't change the model and it
would cancel out as well when you do
those ratios exactly so there's no
information about it right so
there's no point in putting an intercept
because it doesn't contribute
we've talked about a bit about the log
rank test the possibility of tied
failure times right if time is measured
discretely like in months
you might often get more than one
failure or death at a given
failure time and those are kind called
tied failure times
as i mentioned the log rank test can
handle those seamlessly well the cox
model can handle them as well but it's a
little more complicated but if you look
in the software which we mentioned the
end of the course
it's all been figured out by
smart people over the years
but and you might be wondering why the
name partial likelihood
turns out it's not a full likelihood in
a sense and this is again a much more
technical topic but
because of the way it's constructed with
this unspecified h0 of t
it's very convenient but it's not what's
called full maximum likelihood but it's
a very good approximation
so if you're interested more in the
underlying theory of this um i
uh suggest you read more
now
the call
we started off talking about the
kaplan-meier survival curves now the
survivor function was sort of a very a
very important summary of survival data
well from the cox model with covariates
you also are interested not just in the
relative risk parameters but also the
underlying survival curve
now it's a function of t given x
right you'd like to say given an
individual with certain feature vector
like males or females or males with
certain clinical measurements what is
the predicted survival curve
and you can get that from the cox model
as well the entire predicted survival
curve as a function of their features so
that's a bit different from regression
right usually with regression we just
measure the mean of the response given x
at any particular x here we get an
estimate of the entire distribution
exactly
so let's look at now at the proportional
hazards model applied to the brain
cancer data and again here's i mentioned
you get an anova style table
here are the the features here's the
coefficients
the standard errors
the the z statistic which is the ratio
and a
two-sided p-value
and again this is a multivariate model
much like the multivariate models we saw
in regression
they're all fit together and kanawski
index is the only one that's got a
actually not the only one but
these two diagnosis one of the diagnosis
is also very significant high grade
glioma right
and again this is you know this is one
of the brilliant um aspects of this cox
proportional hazards model because it
takes this complicated problem with
censoring and so on and it casts it as a
regression problem with all the usual
statistics it makes it very usable and
that's part of the reason it caught on
right and and the interpretation is in
terms of a relative risk so looking at
karnowski index
this x the remember this
minus this beta of minus 0.05 means that
the
relative risk is exponential of minus
0.05 which is 0.95
so it's saying that that if you have
each unit
in a one unit increase in karnovsky
index corresponds to a
decrease in the relative risk of five
percent so that's something often
confusing to get making sure you get the
signs of the coefficients the
interpretation correct right here it's
negative
which you might normally think is a bad
thing but actually because it's a
relative risk that's being modeled
being negative here is good right
because it's decreasing the relative
risk
so that's an important detail to keep in
mind
and this just
reports the p-value which is truncated
here but it's actually
from the actual table is .0027
another example the publication data set
which is mentioned in the chapter this
is the the time to publication of
journal papers reporting results of
clinical trials reported by the nih
244 trials and the outcome is the time
of months until publication
88 of them were not published at all so
they were censored during the study
period
so this many were published and the
remainder were censored they weren't yet
published so the outcome is time until
publication
lots of covariates here and well i won't
read read through all them here but that
the the one of particular interest was
whether or not the if the clinical trial
had a significant positive result was it
was it more likely to be published
earlier right which is something that i
think people some people believe so that
this study was one to look at whether
the the positive result of the clinical
trial increase the chance of it being
published more quickly and they i wanted
to adjust for lots of different
possible confounding factors
here's the kaplan-meier curves for the
two groups so ignoring the other
features at this point just looking at
the capital mile curves
it doesn't look like there's much
difference and sure enough the log rank
test has a p-value of 0.36
so this is again this negative positive
result refers to whether the clinical
trial reported
a negative or positive result for the
the treatments being compared
and
it looks like
um there's not much difference and
that's ignoring all the other features
right
but we do a multivariate analysis
again using cox is
proportional has this model
what do we have here we have
a very significant p-value for positive
result
right the standard error coefficient
standard error and the z-score and the
impact score of the journal is also
important
and some other guys were largely
important so so what's happened here
trevor how could it be that
these survival curves are so similar but
this is strongly significant
it must been confounded
[Music]
so there's some confounding factors here
that we had to adjust for right
which is the reason why one does these
kinds of multivariate analysis to adjust
for other
other confounding factors and now the
adjustment's been quite dramatic it now
shows that
a
strong positive effect for for
a positive result
in terms of shortening the publication
time
okay
we can actually go one step further with
the in with this multivariate model to
produce adjusted survival curves
so we want survival curves
the s of t given x the estimated
survival curves
for positive negative results and we
want to adjust for the other features
well
when we first plotted those two curves
it was sort of averaged over the other
features you know the positive result
group and the and the negative result
group
just averaged over all the features and
if those features were differently
distributed in those two groups that's
when you have confounding so now we're
going to make sure the features are the
same in the two groups when we look at
the two curves that means we have to
choose some value for those other
features so
and one could choose any values but sort
of the most reasonable is to use the
mean so we use the mean value for each
predictor
for things which are not categorical and
for the categorical prediction mech
which is the the mechanism of funding we
use the most prevalent category ro1
so we set the features to some fixed
value so we can make it now a clear
comparison between positive and negative
i want to look at that and now we see a
clear difference between the survival
curves yeah
what has happened well
you already answered that okay